wenn euer Waschbecken etwas riecht und
sich auch verfärbt hat durch Kaffee oder
Tee nehmt ihr einfach etwas Natron packt
Zitronensäure oder Essig dazu und reibt
das ganze mit einer Bürste ein ihr seht
hier ganz gut dass sich alle
Verfärbungen gut ablösen das ganze könnt
ihr dann noch mit kochendem Wasser
übergießen schön alles Abreiben mit der
Bürste verteilen und gerne auch mit
einem Pfeifenputzer oder einer ganz
kleinen Bürste den Abfluss schön
reinigen so bekommt ihr wirklich alle
Reste weg und falls doch noch Gerüche
übrig sind gebe ich einfach ein bisschen
unikopuro K dazu dann riecht das
Waschbecken auch aus den Rohren richtig
schön sauber jetzt alles gut wegspülen
trocken reiben und euer Waschbecken ist
wieder blitze
blank